welcome to this video playing KS do I
know this guy nope wow he's got 30,000
five-minute games they never played him
I think this is kind of funny ok so I'm
playing a classical Queens gambit here
just being super super solid check the K
checking go back here
yeah this is a slightly refined version
of the clothes catalan wear black was
able to provoke the move Bishop t2 with
his check and this way preventing wide
from setting up his bishop won't be too
for the faint shadow ok so just might be
seven i guess or not ja looks normal if
white plays Knight to c3 that's what I
wanted to say ok it's not relevant if
you take place Knight c3 I could have
maybe taken see form hmm
that flu that's the very weakening way
to play this really is he wants to go if
I am home okay in very interesting i
have many ways to play now i can even
take and play be 54 let's do that it
looks interesting this is implying an
exchange sacrifice but an interesting
one let's let's try this out Bishop c6
rook c8 s is straight away good for me I
think this is just running into an
awkward pin whoops and the screen b6
check and I'm going for that okay let's
win apiece there yeah okay the big the
big challenge was he takes be five which
we don't get on the board now
unfortunately I mean okay I'm winning
this piece and the game but the other
continuing resign what is it much more
interesting I mean okay Bishop c6 is
really strange I mean not that just
queen bee six wins rook c8 also it's
just great um okay the real thing was
the capture and then I'm going to take
here I can click in the check but I
wanted to take and I thought that this
should be quite good for me yeah this
kind of thing I mean quite good well
good compensation at least in a blitz
game well his king is wide open and the
light squares are my my compensation
here Bishop can come to be seven maybe
ever oxy eight with tempo 95 is kind of
backward in development so this is
probably enough compensation the
computer here gives equal yeah maybe I
don't know it's difficult difficult
really to to a sense but certainly
possible in a blitz game yeah came i
also had this one this is what the
engine is suggesting we have very
sensible very sense of what i was it I
was attracted to this to this
to the sacrifice them by the way you can
also ignore this and just continue like
we should be 3 or something let me
capture them this kind of thing but
quite often Black has those ideas or
queen a5 is also moving yeah I think
this should be a good counter play
currently I'm even a poner which is not
that relevant but at least something
white probably has to spend a move at
one moment to to recapture the pawn yeah
I think that was okay in general I think
that this early nights if I cannot be
that that that much of a challenge for
black it's often more interesting for
white to play something like a four a
five trying to use this unprotected
bishop somehow 193 is also an
interesting way to go just ignoring that
this is hanging because you for might be
good compensation or 95 here those ideas
are interesting that he didn't go for
that okay well thanks for watching